i'm truly delighted today to host lan
young who is a path-breaking scholar
working at the intersections of cinema
studies asian american studies
vietnamese studies asian studies
and critical diaspora studies
critical refugee studies and truly is
one of the most important voices at the
intersections of all these fields
dr jung is an associate professor in
cinema and media studies at the
university of southern california
and the author of treacherous subjects
gender culture and trans vietnamese
phenom feminism in a wide range of
important journal articles and book
chapters
i just want to say a word about her book
it's truly path-breaking it introduces
new ways of intersectional analysis that
break down all sorts of disciplinary
boundaries it not only critiques the
legacies of colonialism and imperialism
but takes on the fraught challenge of
engaging with ideologies of
traditionalism gender hierarchy
hierarchies nationalism and does this
all through the provocative concept of
treachery as expressed in both
vietnamese and diasporic
representational practices
and lived experience
for the sake of this gathering today in
the context of a council on southeast
asian studies i want to signal how
important
the book is not only as a work of cinema
studies but for lamb's a complete
scholarly project
being especially important for the way
in which it transcends a deeply
problematic fictional divide that for so
long has separated scholars working in
asian studies from those working in
asian american studies
her concept of trans vietnamese feminism
and her method of studying both vietnam
and the vietnamese diaspora within what
she calls the same coordinates of time
and space for example
is truly a clarion call for more work
that pushes beyond the methodological
nationalism of area studies and also the
u.s centrism of so many other fields
i suspect that the title of today's talk
on water is part of this way of thinking
thinking outside the little buckets of
scholarship we tend to think with i like
to think of water as something that we
pour into buckets and it sometimes takes
the shape of those buckets but if we
jostle the buckets
the water can leap out beyond the bounds
of those buckets and mingle with the
waters of other buckets and take on new
shapes so i'm excited to see what
happens today
when professor jung shakes things up and
gives us new ways of looking at trans
vietnamese cinema social life politics
and history so please join me in
welcoming professor len
young thank you
thank you eric for that wonderful
introduction
it sounds like
both you and my mom read the book so
that's very nice
kidding
but i wanted to say thank you to eric as
well and guangzhon for inviting me and
being a part of this space it's really
an honor and a pleasure to talk to you
today about
my talk on water and refugee
memories in vietnamese diasporic films
so i'm going to share screen now
and i begin with
linen lum's
very beautiful image
called tomorrow i leave
and as you can see there is uh from what
i'm sketching out uh predominance or
preoccupation with water
both
in art and films
of the vietnamese and vietnamese
diaspora
and so today in terms of
films especially i'm going to be talking
about
[Music]
forgetting vietnam
and queen wayne lays nuke
so in terms of looking at these films
i'm looking at them through the lens of
trans vietnamese feminism
and critical refugee studies to argue
that water resonates in these films as
both a membrane as a container
as a bucket to use eric's um term
and as memory
and i argue that it's a conduit for the
transfer of knowledge
and the ocean itself becomes an archive
for dead refugee bodies but also of
stories and secrets
and the films relay this tension and
poignancy both sonically and visually
visually
such works convey waters
rehabilitative mode of tending and
containing
refugee grief and diasporic memory
so i'm going to introduce
three modes of looking
that i use in order to look at these
works
one of them is trans vietnamese feminism
based on the book
treacherous subjects that i've written
so long ago
but it's still relevant to me in terms
of looking
at the
geopolitical arrangements of power in
vietnamese culture
in terms of and i'm
returning to eric's terms here in terms
of seeing
both vietnam and the diaspora in the
same coordinates of time and space
ultimately it's a method of analysis
that looks at these at vietnam
and the vexed relations the country
shares with its foreign others which
include western countries like the us
and france as well as a diaspora and its
outer lying neighbors i focus on those
who have been marginalized by such
politics hence the name treacherous
subjects
because these treacherous subjects tend
to be women
ethnic minorities and sexual minorities
or gender non-biary binary subjects
in terms of critical refugee studies
um
yen lei espiritu and i uh wrote an essay
on syrian vietnamese woman artists and
in this essay we talked about feminist
refugee epistemology or fre
and this was an important concept for us
to
push forward and it is a way to turn
away from the spect spectacularization
of refugees suffering that often
headlines global corporate media
to dislocate the masculinist and
nationalistic forms of refugee memory
that are that are made public in local
and global spaces
and so as you see on the screen here
we looked at syrian born artist nisrin
bukhari in a work installation called
unreceived letters
can you hold on for a bit i should close
my window is can you hear the motor lawn
mower
can anyone hear the light i cannot hear
it no i'm here
that's great
um
and so this is a very quiet uh
installation where bukhari wrote letters
to
her family back in syria she's in the
netherlands right now
exiled from her own country
and she invites the participants to
rifle through the letters you know
making their marks with their fingers on
these pieces of paper
um and read through them within a very
private gendered space as you can tell
with the little doilies
and um
and it's that intimate space of
interiority
that uh espiritu and i wanted to
emphasize
um
on the right you'll see that kind of
interiority
in jin my cuts
quiet
and it's really a mode of
re-typing re-translating some of the
letters that were sent to those who
perished in the seas during their boat
passages
and so the white panels hang from the
ceiling as you can see
the white panels being symbols of
mourning
for those
who were those who died
and so off fre probes the spaces of
interiority and the modes of silence
that inherent them
and
in terms of those modes of silence it's
important for us to
think about
what these silences say
and
what they mean how can we
um look at these spaces and
understand the silences
as well as the ways that um
as kataria um another uh critical
refugee study scholar has said how do we
understand these spaces and these
narratives as ways to restore
uh displacement and she takes the
concept of re restoring from chinua
achebe
and so a crs methodology in short
magnifies the political forces
that underlie
these intimate sites
and quite often the domestic space and
i'll be using that
these kinds of lenses to read the films
as you'll see
another uh
term that i'd like to
introduce here is the idea of refugee
cinema and
what kaur and grassley argue is the open
poetics of fifth cinema and refugee
cinema is an emergent subfield within
film studies
and these authors argue that refugee
cinema is more distinctly a fifth cinema
first cinema being
what hollywood produces second cinema
being the more european art house films
third
are the kinds of films that came out in
the 1960s and 70s
from africa latin america and asia
in a more
mode of decolonization
so fifth cinema is one in which these
authors
argues embodies a multi-faceted spectrum
of films made by or with the active
participation of refugees unquote and
the its aim is to elicit social action
and they call for political resonant and
ris resistant fifth cinema
that outline the innovative often
digitized and dangerous means that
refugees produce their work
and often collaborate with others in
this
mode of media making
so i understand the open poetics of
fifth cinema and i examine these films
to underscore the kind of ethical
political and poetic
um
the ethics poetics and politics that
underlie them
as they relate to refugee memories and
post memories
and today i'll begin with
uh the works of vietnamese diasporic
filmmakers uh chronologically and the
first one
that i'd like to talk about is janan
hung's la pierce de la tante
which was done in 1991 or it's called
the wading stone
um and i bring
this movie
with
vietnamese australian director cuados
motherfish that was made in 2009 because
both of these films are um use a certain
studio setting to talk about
refugee
loss and grief
and then in the second part of my
presentation i'm going to turn to the
more recent films by chinti manha
forgetting vietnam and queen lei's no
both of which were made in 2016
to bring all of my methodological
strands together
and so to place them within a framework
of cinemas that are worth not only
looking at but listening to
so to begin
um john hong as
many of you probably know is the very
famous vietnamese french director of
films like scent of green papaya
and a vertical ray of the sun
and um
this film is actually a student film
which he made when he was a
student in film school in paris
and i am attracted or
drawn to this film because of the ways
in which it really sets a precedent in
in my imagination of the kinds of
critical preoccupations
about women's conditions about
their everyday lives the quotidian and
the ways in which um
aesthetically dunanhol likes to very
much
focus on women's faces and and gestures
so these two films that i'll be talking
about back to back
um
are held together by the slender
aesthetic thread
that pulls them together in my
critical imagination and that is the
unspectacular ways that refugee memories
are housed
in the most minimalist of spaces
the settings for each a bleak parisian
apartment
and a sweatshop that serves as a vessel
for the boat
relay how refugee memories um root
themselves in gendered spaces of
interiority and of the cycle
and
the reason why i um place them under the
ethics of refugee media making
is because
they are refugee
themselves
jannan hong is
and cuado is the second generation uh of
um
refugee uh of um
the the chil he's the child of refugee
clearance in australia
but they tried to be as refugee centric
as possible they wrote their own scripts
and they worked collaboratively with
refugees or the children of refugees in
the making of their films
so here i emphasize
the cinematic refrain
within both of the films and that is the
absence of boats
in lacking the visualization of boats on
screen the two directors underscore more
so the oral aspects of refugee trauma
and
and so that in so doing they draw
meaningfully on the connotations of
water or nook in vietnamese milk as
others have explored means both water
and country but being adrift in water is
a condition germane to the boat people
experience
in which refugees fleeing vietnam after
the vietnam war ended in 1975
um onto rickety boats waiting for rescue
um is a paradigm
paradigmatic experience
for um
for both people
in her evocative essay salt slash water
patrician
turns to performance and her family's
oral histories to theorize how water
invokes freedom quote freedom but also
death
and is the site and material for
disrupting land-based logics of
vietnamese subject formation
epistemologies unquote
so like nguyen i call attention to the
oceans harboring of refugee
subjectivities
and
their
epistemologies
so in terms of
student film la pierre de la tante it's
based on a vietnamese photo called the
waiting stone or home von fu
and it tells the story of patriarchy's
misrecognition of the ancestors other
which is the sister
and the construction of the waiting
woman who's reproduced or produced and
reproduced here as a result of her
loyalty to her husband
after she after they find out or the
brother finds out that they are in fact
both married and
brother and sister
he flees and she returns or she stays in
her home but becomes the waiting woman
and there's actually a rock sculpture in
northern vietnam of the waiting woman
where she is petrified into stone the
figure is
while she's holding her son
so this uh folktale
in the filmic version
um is reused
interestingly in ways that reflect on
the vietnamese refugee experience
and it updates the legend to a more
contemporary setting where the
characters arrive at a refugee camp in
indonesia and are then relocated to
france
and in my mind the move speaks an
innovative
and creative use of a studio setting
where the refugee camp is set
and the draft interiors of an apartment
in paris
so we shift from the camp's barracks
to the blocking lines of a gray building
and the two set pieces are highly
suggestive of the ways that refugee
lives appear to involve endless forms of
waiting
as they are processed as refugees at the
camps and then become immigrants in
their new environs
waiting as it were to begin again
so i wanted to begin
here
with a short clip
of
this moment where we're in um
the camps
and we have john um
who is janan hong's partner and wife
in an earlier
film of his
um who plays the main protagonist
and then we also have
lam lei who is a director vietnamese
french director himself who plays the
brother and in this um introduction i
wanted to have you think about the ways
that again we're in we're set in a
studio setting
which has been redone as
the camps barracks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
okay um
the only
clip that i could get was actually on
youtube
and with spanish subtitles otherwise the
film is only available from what i can
tell in a space called cinema tech in
paris
and that's how i got access to the film
but so
apologies in advance for the subtitles
this introduction though
says a lot through the gestural
and through the use of light
and
the sonic tapestry that i wanted to
have you think about
so this young woman
levers us into the story when she enters
the film frames and steps into the
refugee camp generically named as such
in the french subtitles amid children
playing and men and women talking the
sounds in the camp signal a hum of
activities in the background you also
hear ocean waves and foghorns
and instead of a fishing village as you
see or as you know
from the vietnamese
legend
it's what's cited here is the camp
itself
where the siblings bond as a direct
result of having survived the boat
passage alone during their spare
dialogue the hues of the sequence evoke
a semblance of warmth even as it's set
in the barrenness of the barretts
so i note the sound color and tone of
the scene because they contrast
dramatically with the following scenes
where the couple now husband and wife
live in a parisian apartment complex
that is dreary and devoid of sound
so with this change of scenery
we move from the warm sounds and palette
of the ocean and the camp to a soundless
milieu and the muted colors of their
resettlement in france
so in accommodating the myth to the
story of the vietnamese displaced john
reimagines the folk tale to tell a bleak
story of loss and wars after life
and this reframing further locates the
brother and the husband
and the sister and the wives
estrangement within the confines of
their
new surroundings
so that while the film sounds out a con
confucionist tale about women's
endurance the familial the familial
story that john re tells is lined with
refugee desires to leave
and fears
uh in both their host and home countries
and the devastation of the film then is
integrally tied to vietnamese refugees
and their transnational journeys and the
material and existential losses that
they have occur incurred along the way
so what i argue is that
the film emphasizes a sense of exile and
grief that are restored here in a way
that speaks over the moralistic and
patriarchal overtones of the legend
and the director gestures instead to how
refugees endeavor to not only survive
the oceanic passage but also survive the
resettlement experience as well
i'm going to move on to mother
mother fish
by vietnamese australian cuado
and so like dunan holmes lapia
the film begins with a black screen
replaying in the backdrop voices that
are familiar to an australian public
former australian prime minister kevin
rudd
discusses the draconian raft of refugee
policies called the pacific solution
so you hear in the background
while a black screen plays
of a reporter uh talking or asking prime
minister rudd on the pisces on the
possibility of reopening christmas
island as a site to process asylum
claims
and rudd vaguely responds there's a
purpose-built facility there for that
purpose
so following this empty rhetoric that
there's a sound bridge of running water
that leads us into the kitchen
where a vietnamese woman
soundlessly prepares a meal
so from here we move to a factory
setting where the refugee passage is
again reenacted and reimagined
so i wanted to play a quick clip of that
of the film's uh beginning
people when they're intercepted
in australian waters that's where they
go
secondly there's a purpose-built
facility there for that purpose
uh and as far as i know and my recent
advice is there is still capacity there
but as the minister has made plain for a
long long time
capacity of darwin and other places
should that become necessary what we've
dealt with in the last
[Music]
year
okay so in that quick clip you you hear
red's um
voice in a in a voice over that is also
intermingled with the sounds of cooking
um and it's within these unspectacular
confines that the story of vietnamese
boat people really emerges and while
she's preparing her food the woman hears
another woman's voice as you heard which
turns out to be her younger sister hun
speaking to her playfully in an interior
monologue that plays out in the
beginning and end of the film
but what also begins and ends with the
but what also begins and ends the film
are the sounds of
water
and the two sisters reunite in water
actually they're submerged in water
and it's a coming together that we
actually see on screen
but before continuing with kim's story
who is the adult
kim that you see cooking here i'd like
to offer some notes on the pacific
solution
and its devastating impacts on refugees
and asylum seekers
established in 2001 and promulgated by
the rudd government the pacific solution
was designed to refuse refugees on the
grounds that australia needed to defend
its borders
against boat people who were unlawfully
entering the country
arriving on its shores
and part of the solution was the
re-zoning of christmas island which
would no longer receive asylum seekers
and refugees
instead the australian government set up
offshore reception centers
in papua new guinea and nora to
outsource the work of processing
refugees
in 2013 under rudd's direction in his
second term as prime minister a revised
version of the pacific solution was
rolled out
in which this newest iteration of this
law formally enacts the physical
detention of refugees and the
reshuffling of their borders of their
bodies to any other place but australia
and of course the precursor to these
solutions was the problem that inducing
indo-chinese refugees as boat people had
posed when they first came to australia
in the 1970s up to the 1980s
at the time much of australian
conservative political discourse
positioned the india chinese as
imposters
and not bona fide refugees
understood as having left vietnam by
choice and out of economic need
so with these overlapping historical
contexts that begin the film
dole's work insists on restoring the
narratives of vietnamese vote people
and speaking to the vietnamese
australian refugee community
and other refugee
irregular maritime migrants as they're
called in australian
media
who have been refused recently
by the government
and look at these connective tissues
between boat people and recent um
refugees
book and the the film
and it begins with australia's
xenophobic political discourse and ends
on a commemoration of vietnamese boat
people the closing intertitles reveal
that quote around 600 000 of an
estimated 1.5 million vietnamese who
fled their country by boat between 1975
and
1996
perished at sea and unquote
so with this next clip i wanted to show
how he actually cuado actually
visualizes
this boat passage
within a garment um factory space
and it's what once very beautiful and
poignant uh and in other times very
de-realized
um formally because one has to fill in
the spaces of
the space of the boat
and so here's a quick clip
to exemplify that
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
and i'm gonna get some more food
[ __ ]
maybe not useful
so i'll stop there but you can see the
steeples of you know the um red cones of
thread in the back you see this kind of
rusted
manufacturing equipment that offer
viewers an imaginative invitation to see
that this is the whole of the boat
and so in so doing though forces the
viewer to imagine the imaginable
unimaginable with sounds and images of
water as mnemonic devices
that allow the viewer to be wrapped up
in or i'm sorry um wrapped up in the
emotional tides of the film
so as it plays out as you see the mo the
main protagonists here are the two
sisters and the one of the sisters do
not um
survive
so my dual focus in terms of looking at
laptop
and mother fish
is to look at both the setting and the
sound of the familiarity of these
stories and their formalism as a way to
alienate in a brechtian way the viewer
from the surroundings
and they are all of these elements are
part of the criticality that i believe
challenge
wields wield in producing
refugee-centered films
that in turn speak to and
about refugees
um
which i think leads us to the other two
films that i'd like to speak about
um within the first two set of films the
we are very much in a
private space
and i think forgetting vietnam and nuke
are also two films that talk about
water and sea
um in ways that more
um
more obviously to me or more apparently
to me
through what i call is a trans
vietnamese feminist lens
so i want to talk about in the next
portion um
in this presentation about the caring
for
the living and for the dead and it's a
trope that i find as a critical refugee
scholar very compelling in
in reading the cultural productions of
the vietnamese diaspora
refugee memory
and critical inquiry
are what i see as being
centralized in these two films
in such ways that these experimental
works
by women and queer filmmakers
expound on water silence and intimacy
but also the open uh
breaks open the possibility of
critiquing the state
and allowing for a queer sociality
within these spaces
so as i argue for both of the films
water is especially incubative and
maternal the source of life-giving
properties as well as as well as the
holder of secrets
against the vietnamese state
and i'll be talking about
uh for forgetting vietnam first
it's dedicated to the memories of those
who survived the war
and the film forges then a deep cristate
a critique of the state and is really
lined with memories of the hereness of
the country
which is captured on digital video
but also the absent bodies of those who
did not survive
the boat passage
whose bodies are not actually
represented on screen either
and my argument is that you hear these
stories and you see the images and you
hear the lapping of the waves and again
those devices
um
are mnemonic
devices for us to remember and reimagine
those
dead bodies
so forgetting vietnam archives personal
collective memory by way of a travelogue
um touring vietnam in this way is
important for me in
seeing how a diasporic identity
through chinti menha's perspective is a
sieve through which the works affects
are filtered and it's marked by the
state this diasporic perspective is
marked by the state as an outsider a
former traitor to the nation
but the
but with this
kind of subjectivity
um this this vietnamese diasporic
subject is allowed i think a way in to
critique the state
forgetting vietnam
is critical of the state's ongoing
operations to forget
and erase the histories of those who
have survived the war
doing so by representing war again as
the keeper of secrets and knowledge
and in this short clip
we have um
a vietnamese bus driver talking about
these secrets and one of the things that
um chinti minha does throughout the film
actually is to conjoin the idea that um
nuke
and dutt or nuke are conjoined together
in vietnamese
and vietnamese eye sport memories
and so while we're he's talking the bus
driver we see expanses and expanses of
land most notably of rice fields
later on the the film has a lot of shots
of moving waters as well
but in this clip we hear then the ways
in which um the
the people working class people vietnam
are often very critical of the state
[Music]
um
so forgetting vietnam addresses how both
land and water as that vanuk
constitute the country's complex memory
scape
signaled by these images of land and
water the film most insistingly cites
the sea
as meath
and man
as more amniotic than traumatic
and jin's forgetting vietnam makes a
case then for the ways that water stores
knowledge and retains memories of those
that had been disappeared by the state
a notion reinforced by the fact that
nuke as the film notes early on means
both water and country
and um
invokes the origin story of oka
and la langkwan
whereby the separation of the people has
been born out of loss and love
forgetting rehearses the country's
original trauma
of separation
to reflect then upon the divisions that
have also strike striated vietnam's past
and present
the painful divisions that have marked
north and south
as well as the divisions between vietnam
and the diaspora
i'm going to move on to quinwyn lesnook
because if chintiman has filmed dwells
on dutnuk to
speak of vietnam and warn against its
forgetting of refugee lives
lay six minutes short note concretizes
the imagery of vietnamese land
specifically its production of rice and
water through the evocations of food and
food making
so that what runs through the film
are acts of making and eating food
specifically chao or rice porridge which
is constituted by both rice and water
in fact liquids run as a current from
beginning to end we're in we're first
situated in a photography dark room
where chemicals and water are used to
create memory and culture most
specifically
of photographs of family and of the war
and the associations between the gender
queer subject that is at the heart of
the film
and the mother
become more clarified as the film
continues
and what we have on this um image that
you see
is that hua the mother and rosie eat
jiao
the scenes are composed of a
concise study
they compose a concise study in the ways
that the two subjects are often
nourished not only through daily food
but also through the vital stories they
tell one another
the emphasis on these unspectacular
refugee acts
as they're recreated in refugee cultural
productions
is critical as espiritu and i have
argued the everyday and the intimacies
between diasporic subjects are the
foundations for what we argue are
feminist alliances and refugee
knowledges
[Music]
a feminist refugee epistemology inheres
in the everyday objects
within a context of silence and quietude
and
allows us to see the feminist and queer
visual practices by which refugee
artists reclaim the private space
as a gendered and queered space
expressive of loss and grief but also of
creative
improvised
and experimental refugee making
practices
so here as you'll see in the clip
there is a primal relationship between
mother and gender career subject
that constitutes the film's main
affective artery
just to give you some context uh what
you see is rosie here
in
performing a kind of gestational labor
pulling out
um
a bloody umbilical cord
and
then there's a very quick juxtaposition
to another scene of being of rosie being
pulled out of a boat by her mother by
their mother
[Music]
baby
[Music]
i think she'd like that too
[Music]
so as um
earlier you saw a painful scene of
gestation and labor uh whereby rosie
tries to get the cord out but with the
same kind of pooling gesture in the next
shot we see the mother pulling rosie out
of water onto a boat in effect saving
their life and steering them towards
safety
so
water here
is a life-giving power that's vested in
the maternal figure and it illuminates
on the grief that is inherited between
the generations between those subjects
who have survived the war
as in as seen in the figure of hua the
mother
and those who have survived it's after
aftermath those who are like rosie
as a second generation
subject
in the metaphorical and affective
registers of the film
fluidity between these temporalities
spatial geographies genders as well as
generations is symbolized by water
water is this liquid encasement that
fuses together mother with motherland
life with a queer feminist lineage and
that which finds the diasporic subject
to
the motherland
or nuke
so that it's appropriate that in the
concluding scene of the film it features
rain
as their iterative acts of cleansing and
renewal and it demonstrates how the two
protagonists come together
surrounded by water
their mundane act of eating sharing food
and silence becomes an opening between
them a revolutionary act of making space
for queerness within the home
as seen in the last line of dialogue the
mother invites rosie's friend to eat in
their home to eat dal
in nuke the complicated labors that the
diasporic subject has to navigate
is affected by way of a meaningful
dialogue a dialectical relationship with
both mother and mother land
so in conclusion
in the films that i've analyzed here
from lapierre de la taunt to mother fish
for getting vietnam to nuke
water archives the lives and memories of
the vietnamese diaspora
some of whom work to illuminate on the
refugee hoods that have lined their
family histories and
their memories
and in closing i end here on a shot from
tinting
for getting vietnam
and i
contend here and elsewhere for the
critical modes of diasporic and refugee
ways of knowing that occur in silence
speech
in images of art and film in terms of
water and ocean
and i can join uh the study of diasporic
refugee cinema with a focus on water to
gesture towards country sustenance and
the maternal at once
and i can join the study of cinema
with critical uh refugee studies as well
as trans vietnamese
feminism
in conclusion um
i'd like to emphasize that the waters of
the ocean as framed in these four films
as heard in these four films
in its beauty and
volatility has contained the bodies of
refugees but also holds in its expansive
folds the possibility of knowledge
and such epistemologies continue to
inspire
refugee art and diasporic art media and
criticism and it behooves us
to look and listen in
thank you
thank you land so much for this
wonderful talk
um so we will now open uh open it up to
q a um let me see i'm going to stop this
screen share yeah or maybe you can do it
on your side yeah
so we can see everybody okay nice
i'm going to say in advance that my
computer just crashed a moment earlier
at the very beginning of the talk so if
i disappear keep talking and i'll try to
get back on
but so basically anyone who has a
question you can use the hand raise
function and i'll call on you and create
a queue and then we'll proceed from
there
juan you have a question go ahead
thanks so much lan for this very
generative um talk
i was really struck by your phrasing of
how refugee memories you know emerge
and facilitate and um
are on display in unspectacular places
um and and i think of you know there's
also in the context of water and the
vietnamese context
water can also be very spectacular
right so i'm thinking about flood
i'm thinking about
the salinization of
fresh water
and and those are also sites of refugee
producing
dynamics
so i was just wondering if you could
maybe speak a little bit more on sort of
this you know water as a trope water is
the metaphor
but also the differentiation between
different kinds of water um if that
resonates in your work
yeah absolutely thank you gwen
um so in my writing i i've talked about
water in its more
i guess generative and and productive
modes
um as a space of loss but from that loss
the generation of
memories and stories and knowledges
um in other ways
water can be and i wanted to pull out
that tension a little bit more water can
be very threatening
water
especially in
vietnamese horror films
which i um
claim to have knowledge on actually
because i've taught asian horror films
um and write about them
water is um a dangerous element um to be
submerged in water and to die in the
water is to be away from one's home
ancestral home
and to be bloated um and so that is
something to be feared
and um and it's a horrifying aspect of
some of the
horror films that i've looked at
and then so in terms of flooding which
is um
a very
important critical fact of vietnamese
life i would love to think about
its productive
properties and the ways in which it
actually brings
people together
and
i don't know if this is
going in the direction that you wanted
me to take you to but there is a comedy
or a movie called um
bow yeah
and i recently seen it unfortunately
because
um i have a tendency to watch bad
vietnamese films but
so in in the setting of that film the
family comes together because then
they're in an alley and the the film has
scenes of uh flooding within this um
within this family community space and
it's that water um that brings them
together um
and as the film continues it's what
brings them together bonds them together
as a unit
um but also
as as the story goes also the family
unit is broken apart by these
um lingering resentments and family
bonds so i think that there are ways we
could argue for how water can be
very multi-valent
in um
lived experiences in vietnam vietnamese
lived experiences but then also how
allegorically in film um and for me
aesthetically how water acts as an agent
in many ways to
conjure
to act as a mnemonic device to remember
and to grieve
thank you gwen
i'm gonna jump in on that because i was
thinking
during the whole presentation about
neiman windvault's film
molendro
because that film i think actually gives
you a really great opportunity to speak
about that double meaning of flood
as both like disaster and regeneration
because the whole setting of that film
is about the way in which uh the floods
come but they also create the
opportunity for
you know regeneration of life and all
those kinds of things but it creates
this kind of traumatic setting as well
right
and i think the history of the mekong
delta in many ways
kind of actually stereotypically
sometimes even northern vietnamese when
they will talk about the mekong delta as
this kind of place of immense fertility
it's a it's a huge stereotype but it's
persistent right they used to say like
you can go to the make on delta and just
stick your hand in the water and you'll
get a fish and that's why southern
vietnamese people
are you know have an easier life than
northern vietnamese people or something
but at the same time there's also this
deep history of flooding
also the the future
um
so that i just thought that'd be a
really interesting angle to look at and
also his follow-up film nook but i
forget the year that's at 20 30 or
something only 30. yeah so
2030 also has this kind of double edge
to it right
um but my question for you
is about the temporality of this
this phrase you used when you were
talking about the sea
as
becoming amniotic as opposed to
traumatic
and i say temporality because i'm
wondering
does it make sense to say there's a
historical shift in the symbolic meaning
of the sea
like for example because
you know
immediately after 75 the sea
can have a kind of traumatic symbolism
but then perhaps historically over time
the meaning of the sea becomes
recuperated in some kind of way and or
is it just sort of a flexible symbol
that can change
in the hands of a different artist or
something like that right i think and so
i'm gonna agree with your last final uh
your second point about its fluidity and
its flexibility to hold
different kinds of um
allegorical and critical import and um
and i'm not arguing that then water is
a temporal or a historic um but i am
looking very specifically about how
uh vietnamese diaspora and refugees are
using this uh element of water
um to draw on
its historical and cultural significance
in vietnamese culture
and in vietnamese lived experiences but
also to focus on
the
um
how the diaspora understands i think
through water
what home and homeland mean so i i once
um
it's flexible um at the end on the other
hand
how i'm understanding water
for the vietnamese diaspora uh
filmmakers that i look at they're very
specific to how
uh water seems to contain secrets and
knowledge as well as um
the actual dead bodies of refugees
and i'm happy to see that wing ball kuhn
is here
i don't want to call her out but
her brother did both films and so happy
to
see you
it's been so long
and i do talk about nuke 2030 i think
it's a beautiful film
um and i i that speaking of temporality
then the fact that it's um so centrally
placed um
in a scientific uh sci-fi imaginary of
saigon being submerged by the sea i
think there is so much to talk about in
in that
act in that actuality of being flooded
um the actuality of environmental harm
and the perhaps you know the generative
notion of water um
as a way to understand
a kind of futurity that hasn't really
been
i think dealt with in some of the
vietnamese films that i've seen so it is
definitely important uh to talk about
um
men's work in this context as well
thanks there's another question from ian
[Music]
hi professor lang thank you for your
presentations
um
my questions for you is that i see and
for clips that you present in your
presentations the lack of urban skates
and as i would wonder if
the relationship between the symbolic
water and the water body
has something related with the um
with the more underdeveloped past of
vietnamese contemporary vietnamese
society
do the diasporic community focus on how
to portray water as something
related with
poverty and
um economics um under development or not
or if there's any other interpretations
on the water relating with urban escapes
and
urbanizations thank you
so um
so you notice then that there are
scenes of urban spaces in
perhaps a film like nuke by queen lay
and but there's also where they are in a
suburban home finally um
eating uh together and
and ending on that note of um
offering chao to rosie's front queer
friend
and then also in uh cuados mother fish
we begin with
the older sister keem
preparing food within the kitchen is
that are these the spaces that you're
talking about
yes um
well then i also think of argentina's
hands
for what's your clips showing it's that
um when she's returning to vietnam or
when she filmed it in vietnam the waters
and the lands kind of like having the
sense of
um
like the more rural uh uh rural spaces
rather than the urban spaces and um
janet homes films is
basically in a refugee camp yeah and a
parisian apartment so um yeah there is
that duality i think of
um
of being in
both land and water i think that's part
of the dialectic that tintee minhau
wants to emphasize in the work
and i think that the
observation that you make about these
different spaces
is key to
my larger argument about how refugees
reimagine
in very particular ways how
the boat passage has
how they have experienced the boat
passage through actual lived memories or
through post memories and how then
there's a continuity from that space
like for example in the refugee camp to
the parisian art our apartment there's a
continuity between forms of waiting
in that camp to forms of waiting in the
apartment building and in fact the
apartment building that we see
is actually less dreary is much more
dreary than the refugee camp and so that
juxtaposition of these different spaces
i think allows us to see the kinds of
psychological states
too of
their
of refugee subjectivities and their
memories and how the associations
between
the home life and work space are really
flooded to use
a term we talked about before flooded
with memories of the boat passage of a
refugee life of refugee death
so thank you then for that observation
hi
hyland
thank you so much for your wonderful
presentation on the topic um
jeffree g's uh cinema which uh this is
amazing because
in film studies it's this stitch more
than one the first second and third side
over um and now you talk about the fifth
cinema
i'm i'm so glad to
learn more about it and learn more about
you know outside the first and the
second which is
it is
great to explore that kind of
possibilities to
think of cinema
uh outside of
western oriented oriented oriented or
based uh theories
so um
i really appreciate and
i'm very uh you know
in inspired by your discussion of uh
water as a troop in
diasporic filmmakers
films and also the ways that is
represented as a architect of
refugees memories i have a particular
question in terms of um
not only the representation but i'm
curious like if you in your work brother
you know a project um would you discuss
anything about for example the the the
kind of like this is not just the
representation but the
the
the wave that cinema is uh was actually
brought to
from the country to outside of the
country because like um
recently i think two years ago i read a
case study i don't remember what is the
film title but um it is about a film
that
was lost otherwise
a filmmaker brought it with him but then
it's lost somewhere and then somebody
took it uh
and then later into hong kong and then
it's returned to him in australia so i
think that kind of consider theme as an
object which is uh with traveled uh you
know on on
on water as a you know uh this is more
in the physical terms
rather than a representational
terms i mean like that's part is it's
wonderful already so i'm wondering if
you uh you know consider in in that
sense and also the second question i'm
curious is you uh discussed um
the
representation in diasporic films
and i
i'm wondering if you discussed it within
the
connections to the vietnamese film
tradition or or only focus on um on um
on on that part like jeffree's cinema
and yeah
that is two questions that i have thank
you um i really
like the first um question i like the
second two but uh the first question
about the material
materiality of films and how they too
have traveled on
sea
in at sea and through waterways
i think that's
something that i want to look about look
into a lot more closely because some of
the films that were made in pre-75
saigon for example did have to make it
outside of the country
in 75 and i can think of a couple of um
examples for example with kyujin's work
who
left
vietnam in 75 and who had to transport
some of her um
beloved films with her i don't think she
went by sea but
but it was a mode of travel um in which
uh she felt like these were
material and cultural artifacts that
needed to be saving needed to be saved
another um
mode of travel uh through airplanes that
uh vietnamese films have traveled
through
is when the library of congress oh i'm
sorry when the american government in
withdrawing from vietnam also took a lot
of films especially done by the us
government and brought them to the
library of congress
and that's where a lot of um
these films are archived
and then finally in the more
contemporary version of
traveling films we now have a very
vibrant
passageway between vietnam and the
diaspora in terms of films whereby
vietnamese
the vietnam film festival in orange
county often
invites
directors and films from vietnam to
screen their works and we have then
another passage of vietnamese american
directors for example from california
who go to saigon specifically to make
films so in this context
films and filmmakers are constantly
circulating and so it's an interesting
um
geography that i'm
that i've looked into
in my work
so
and it relates to the second question do
we have because
this is where
my method of analysis trans vietnamese
feminism tries to
um
put into place and that is if i'm
looking at something in terms of the
vietnamese diaspora i'd like to see how
to vietnamese filmmakers have
looked at
or represented water so as you know
there is
along the same river
the famous you know film of
two lovers who are separated at the
um 17th parallel between north and south
um they are surrounded by water and i
talk about how that kind of um
passageway
um between uh
north and south
peasants because they're also fishers
are treated differently in a communist
film like that
um and
so
and water has more of a kind of
a pragmatic way of travel we see a lot
of
traveling on the
um
[Music]
women on the perfume river for example
by nutmeg
and she uses it as also a way to um
it's a space for
her sex work on the boat
and so finally in another film
called sister hau orti
um she the woman who's just been raped
um played by jazzan
goes to the ocean
and she's about to commit suicide
and then she turns around because she
hears her baby crying and it's at this
point of this very poignant pivotal
moment where she realizes that she will
mother the country and mother and
continue to mother her child
at that moment we get a juxtaposition of
the ocean plus her breast and she is
breastfeeding the baby so there are
different ways in which vietnamese
directors have understood water and
ocean and it's in my writing that i try
to tease out those important differences
and attachments to water
thanks wonderful thank you so much i
look forward to reading your
writings on this topic very much thanks
um
we are basically at the end of our time
here usually what i do is i stop the
recording now and then we keep it open
for a few minutes for informal chit chat
so
let's all join me in a round of applause
and then i'll stop the recording
thank you